no es el más conocido de los
expresidentes chinos pero las decisiones
de yang zemina influyeron profundamente
en la trayectoria que tomó su país a
finales del siglo 20 por aquel entonces
china quería abrirse al mundo
especialista en economía este hombre con
reputación de duro al principio fue
designado por el partido comunista para
gestionar las inversiones extranjeras
una cuestión clave y una señal de la
confianza que ya se había depositado en
él eran los primeros años de la década
de 1980 yankemin subió escalafones
rápidamente en 1985 se convirtió en
viceministro y alcalde de Shanghai su
ciudad natal dos años más tarde entró en
el buró político del comité central del
partido único el primer punto de
inflexión en su carrera el año 1989 los
acontecimientos de la plaza de tiananmen
en las calles estudiantes intelectuales
y trabajadores todos ellos exigían
reformas y más democracia la revuelta
Popular fue reprimida con sangre pero
pronto contemplaron nuevos vientos un
mes después yang cemina fue nombrado
secretario general del partido comunista
chino la consagración llegó en 1993
elegido presidente de la república acabo
de convertir al país en una economía de
Mercado en diciembre de 2001 china entró
en la Organización Mundial del Comercio
la entrada de china en la omc aportará
una nueva vitalidad al crecimiento
económico de china Así como al de otros
países y regiones de Asia y otros
lugares
una decisión que valió la pena ya que a
partir de entonces sin experimentó un
auge económico sin precedentes yankemin
fue también quien rompió con el
aislamiento diplomático de Beijing
Especialmente cuando reestableció las
relaciones con Estados Unidos tras la
crisis de Taiwán en 1996